bella tutti ragazzi e poi venuti questo
video sono fa vj ragazzi non temo nulla
neanche il freddo tanto che indosso le
magliette a maniche corte e anche
d'inverno ragazzi oggi fa un freddo
della madonna
segnatevi questo [ __ ] data perché non
si ripeterà mai più
oggi mi è scappata oggi io cedu al
freddo
adesso va meglio con chi ragazzi prima
di comino veramente ciò che un freddo
cane direi di partire con la parate la
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vita l'ambiente di testa che riesco
manca muovere il braccio e questa
settimana è stata vinta da marcello
cavallo ragazzi questo è l'unico ragazzo
al mondo capace di fare un disegno della
madonna
non ci posso credere io non ho parole
veramente c'è la capra e bellissima
abbiamo saputo dimostrare che anche le
sere maschile sa fare qualcosa oltre
bere birra guardare tipi di ragazzine
che possiamo passare alle news e psi
come lega non ho tante news oggi ne ho
una che però è forse la news più
fantastica che io abbia mai detto da
quando da quando faccio blog pronti lega
perché
sto facendo così perché devo trovare il
file dove l'ho scritta
eccolo ragazzi siete pronti ho finito le
tic tac ed e una cosa triste questa
ragazzina che possiamo passare lo scarta
già dei pacchi oggi sono più triste del
solito ed è il blog più strano che abbia
mai fatto nella storia non riesco
neanche ad alzarmi costa roba ecco che
bello ragazzi oggi ne apro 4 non te
precoci sono sono più bello tra tutti i
pacchi come al solito non poteva mancare
quello che si distingue dagli altri
credo che parli da solo sta roba ragazzi
anche sito web da tre è grosso come una
bara dentro ci sarà un morto inizio
prima con gli altri che è meglio tanto
c'è questo che mi inquieta un casino
tipo non so perché partiamo questa roba
che non ci ho paura solo a guardarlo
cioè io poi veramente capire come mai
tutti i mimi mimì le scatole delle
scarpe dell'adidas per farmi i pacchi
non l'ho mai capita sta cosa per apriamo
il coseca mie cose cosa dovrebbe mai
essere questa cosa credo di avere appena
trovato il mio scopo nella vita
a parte questo ragazzi poi c'è una cosa
fa vi risponde a c'è anche il fare
risponde indossa la nel vino che ti
abbiamo spedito please
guarda io io prevedo il futuro amico mio
io sapevo di questa domanda quindi lo
avevo in testa cosa sia ma perché mi
inviate ste cose floreali qualcuno di
voi mi deve spiegare che cosa sto
facendo della mia vita sono partito che
ero così è
siamo finiti così in tipo cinque minuti
ciao favi guardiamo sempre i tuoi video
ci saluti appena per il nostro pacco
grazie daniele milano grazie daniela e
milena per questa cosa bella che ho
addosso e infine ragazzi c'è una fan
alta di com'ero io ho un tempo prima di
diventare così aver ragazzi passa al
prossimo the meglio ke e bella un'altra
scatola di amazon riciclata c'è scritto
aprì subito prima che il pacchetto
esploda e poi c'è il counter su 7 che
credo sia così da 800 mesi delle delle
mentine di topolino
cioè io io sono senza parole giurie la
carta igienica che ho scritto un summit
guarda della carta igienica finita quasi
con su scritto usami sicuramente di ogni
giorno che passa ragazzi minuti diete
perchè ancora per i vostri pacchi non lo
so non so trovato un pacco regalo dentro
un parte da tale di nuovo siamo al 23 di
gennaio se non sbaglio ma chi se ne
fotte
e così che fitch ha itf fatta coi
fiocchi non ebbe sei un genio ci siamo
ragazzi c'è dentro e te pareva che cazzo
ci doveva essere varzi della nutella
ragazzi anche dei soldi ovviamente finti
una banana berlusco su scritta i love
you di smart su una banana è veramente
la cosa più romantica che abbia mai
visto
queste le ho fatte per portarmi il tuo
nome è sempre con me e valeria che hai
fatto a haifa ha fatto delle scarpe con
su scritto valeria e l'altra c'è scritto
fabi j
cioè io voglio farlo concorrenza la nike
e la destina avanti sappiate che la e la
banana comunque testimonia il nostro
amore e valeria oh mio dio a chiazze
peluche con scritto mi manchi tanto
grazie
per concludere ragazzi il parto col
pacco swag perché mica sembrano uno
stereotipo secondo voi era permesso
pacco
secondo me no un dizionario italiano
inglese inglese ha adesso mi spieghi
perchè mi hai mandato un dizionario
quindi ragazzi o che la lasciamo perdere
che me direi che possiamo passare al fa
vi risponde io e la mia banana qua siamo
contenti di tutto questo rende
nell'ultimo pacco per ora la scritta
sveglia era carina la prima domanda
arriva da mini one imac stato risponde è
ancora stili
[Musica]
ma quanto sono bello ragazzi che cosa
cazzo appena guardato davide martini
fare il fai un video dove limiti le
varie tipologie di fan che hai spolli
chat e una sfida
devi sapere ragazzi se volete che lo
facciano a me piace come idea non è male
sarà style sull'ultima non sarà mica per
harry styles
non credo l'ultima canzone che gli
ascoltato è think in out loud di agire e
di fare risponde farvi puoi fare un
video su dax medda dub smooth doubs mi
fai un vino slavo che lei ci provo
[Musica]
beh
questo era quello che avete visto voi
questo è quello che è successo davvero
una cosa ai bei bei bej oh bej oh bej oh
bej cervello doubs proprio bello accordo
ragazzine che possono chiude qui la
prima di concludere la fabi domanda
perché sono toccati nonché ragazzi la
favi domanda di oggi è la fai domandati
o sono molto più trendy così volete che
faccia quel video sulle tipologie di fan
in generale ve lo chiedo perché siete
voi a decidere chi cazzo di capelli
ragazzi fatemi sapere se il video è
piaciuto porca [ __ ] servito è piaciuto
ma sente lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a facili facebook economy vino
trovata una descrizione sostenuto i siti
scelti ci vediamo al prossimo vito belle
ragazze